[Musica]
era tutti i ragazzi e per minuto che
sono video sono fuori j oggi è halloween
quindi mi sono impegnato un sacco per
vedere questo video a tema halloween
c'è chi si traveste c'è chi si trucca da
zombie tanto da sembrare uno zombie vero
c'è chi diventa uno slider merce chi fa
un sacco di cose incredibili per
halloween dio che ho 4 milioni di
iscritti che quindi devo tenere testa a
tutte queste persone ad halloween corso
ho deciso di fare ho aggiunto un effetto
la webcam
qual è l'obiettivo del gioco scusatemi
dieci minuti per vincere quindi io ho
sono quello che trova tutte le sfere e
devo trovare devo ammettere con sopra o
sono quello che spaventa gli altri
quindi io possono essere sia quello che
prende i job seeker che quello che vita
cosa devo fare
smart sfiga trovato anche io sono quello
spaventato filippo garantite pare ma io
sono deve uscire di quasi amica tipo in
amnesia è una figata
questo trovato qua eccola l'ho trovata
prefetto la prima ho trovato subito prof
ok una rottura l'omessa stessa roba qui
ci sono sempre dei poteri che io trovo
in giro va bene
bastava trinceramenti questi sono i job
seeker quindi mi spunta una testa a caso
questo è il punto cosa sta succedendo
vacca che c'è 11 in questa stanza aiuto
allora tipo deve farci spaventare tre
volte per vincere va beh sì qua ok aiuto
datemi un altare determinata sì ma dove
andrà avanti per danni cazzo righe
perfetto
[Applauso]
sì va bene siamo neanche più 800 punti
perché c'è la madre [ __ ] adesso
sempre pronto pietro giocare questo
gioco molto bello che ho appena
scaricato molto simpatico e spaventato
vendite allora ho capito come funziona
funziona semplicemente tu cileno
spaventerà vicende che sarebbe non avevo
capita di mine cose siamo invisibili
siamo anche tutti in questa scuola tutti
e due invisibili
quando uno capisce dove l'altro poi
spaventarlo contro la barra spaziatrice
quindi io pensavo ci fosse uno che
spaventavano che mi ha spaventato invece
visto sbagliato tutti ii spaventiamo c'è
se vedi qualcosa in volteggia in aria
vuol dire che che sono io che ho
qualcosa in mano e tu non mi vedi i
livelli ad esempio delle cure e quella
barra spaziatrice
esatto ok ho capito che si gioca insomma
adesso ho capito se spaventi tre volte
di fila 1 vinci e se non l'obiettivo è
fare più punti possibili
nel mentre anticate incredibile adesso
ho capito come funziona le rune che
trovi in giro di l'anno dei poteri
quindi ok fighissimo mi piace un sacco
adesso video c'è anche di più
quindi io devo trovare quelle blu today
trovare quelle rosse ok di bianco averlo
avviso girato il bello andare in una
zona di maratta dipende solo bolero l'ha
seguita a e come fa con letture quella
zona ne prendo io mi fai ancora
spaventare ammazzo di botte come premi
un orbo rosso ti indica la bussola
tipica dover andare adesso il tuo rosso
in corridoio anche il mio e corridoio
boni di catel a indicargli call coso qua
che natura sia nominata parte all'inizio
io ti sono all'indicazione e ti vedo e
sono tuo avversario
c'è questo devi fare è giusto è
diventato ora no perché no madonna che
ti spiego io sono una persona su davies
poi io faccio esattamente quello che
stai facendo tu vedi che c'è anche il
mio altare blu quando tu mi vedi mi puoi
spaventare perché l'obiettivo è anche
spaventare avversario perché sono
spaventi loro allenti sono spariti tre
volte e bici a tavolino e in più c'è più
tempo per fare le due cose hai capito
e poi comunque il gioco finisce quando
finisce il timer cup
basta tra l'altro a perché ti ha
spaventato tre volte di più ma che
cavolo gioco bruttissimo questa è bella
che so perché perdi vorrei sono rosso
vai ti do anche un po di vantaggio
perché devo ordinare la pizza
ok cav acchiapparne maledetto ma basta
ancora poi trovarmi sempre basta 26
maledetto unto l'aido mamma che siamo a
pari ad esso si ripartì da zero
così è successo qua è tesissima cosa
cosa sta succedendo e diventa tutto buio
o sei stato tu della clinica n perdono
per le palle come dove teoricamente
questa regola non vale
ho già visto scena un film ho fatto per
sbaglio da te lo giuro la sua terra
lontana che visto l'ho fatto uno sbaglio
culo voti giorno l'ho fatto per sbaglio
non l'ho fatto neanche apposta che cool
eco avuto culo e purissimo non l'ho
fatto manca opposta che culo lo
schiacciato per sbaglio eri limature
rivisto no va fango e vai che caga
incredibili facenti giuro ma per libri
l'anno studiati bene c'è un effetto
sonoro tv fai forte di bruxelles
mancamenti secondi ho vinto io non sono
stato mai trovarti perché tu non lo sai
ma quando fai vai veloce sprint ittiri
veli a mi chiamano sapeva a mi vedevi
spesso vediamo sempre io
987 riuscito grave carte armi perché
time's up vale ragazzi basta è stato
bello giocare con pietro a questo gioco
tranquillo come se vi piace molto mi
piace anche ai torinesi sticciano
l'incasso pietro consensi prestigiamo
schiera al posto mio
e scegliamo costruite che riusciamo a
volte riprenderli io e quindi ho
chiamato il seno perfetto di richiamo
anche le prossime volte bene grazie
[Musica]